I've never flown an airplane like this
where you can control the motion of the
airplane so precisely
I'm not sure we've even scratched the
surface yet of what this airplane when
it's operating with other F-35 is going
to be able to do
the f-35b is arguably the most advanced
plane ever made a jack of all trades a
stealth fighter plane combining and
improving on the capabilities of the
F-16 AV AP Harrier and the B2 a highly
maneuverable fighter plane capable of
attacking both airborne and ground-based
targets a stealth fighter taking the
lessons learned from lockheed's previous
Ventures into stealth with the F-22
Raptor and the F-117 Nighthawk a plane
fitted with the most advanced sensors
and computer systems sharing information
almost instantly with allies without
compromising stealth and presenting the
information directly on a heads-up
display on the Pilot's helmet visor
giving unparalleled situational
awareness allowing a flight of f-35s to
effectively fight as a hive mind perhaps
most boldly of all the f-35b is capable
of transitioning from horizontal to
Vertical flight with a push of a button
using directional thrust and a massive
vertical turbofan engine hidden within
the plane's body making it possible to
land like a helicopter on the relatively
small amphibious assault ships of the US
Marines this is the insane engineering
of the f-35b
fitting all these capabilities into a
single airframe is an extremely
difficult task designing for stealth
demands careful molding of the exterior
of the plane dictating the design of
crucial features creating unavoidable
trade-offs there are a lot of
misconceptions about Stealth the goal
isn't to make the aircraft invisible it
will be detectable the goal is to delay
enemy detection for as long as possible
for bomber aircraft it shrinks the range
of the enemy's radar stations
potentially opening gaps in radar
defenses and allowing the aircraft to
slip through undetected for fighter
aircraft it provides a critical
Advantage detect your enemy before they
detect you to gain these advantages we
need to make it harder for the radar
receiver to decipher whether the return
signal is just background noise or an
enemy aircraft to do that we need to
minimize the strength of the return
signal there are several mechanisms for
a radar wave to be reflected the most
significant and most obvious way is
through spectral return otherwise known
as regular reflection like a mirror
where the angle of reflection equals the
angle of incidence we want to avoid
large flat surfaces that could reflect
straight back to the radar receiver
Corner reflectors where two surfaces are
set at a 90 degree angle to each other
need to be avoided at all costs tail
planes consisting of the vertical and
horizontal stabilizer are the perfect
surfaces to create a corner reflector
allowing radar to bounce off both
surfaces and return right back in the
direction it came the best way to avoid
this is to remove the tail completely
like the B2 but this impacts
maneuverability greatly instead we can
replace both the horizontal and vertical
stabilizer with a v-tail as seen on the
F-117 Nighthawk the v-tail can act as
both a Rudder and an elevator and we can
see how by examining the resultant Force
generated when the controls surfaces are
actuated to different positions we can
actuate them in opposite directions to
generate a horizontal resultant Force
providing yaw control as a vertical
Rudder wood or we can deflect them in
the same direction to provide pitch
control as a horizontal elevator would
this configuration is sometimes used for
Unique looking aircraft like the Cirrus
sf50 allowing it to mount a single tiny
jet engine on top of the fuselage with
its exhaust directed straight through
the detail a private jet so tiny and
lightweight that it can deploy a
parachute to rescue itself in
emergencies having Rudder and elevator
controls linked to a single mechanism
like this is not ideal fighter jets like
the F-35 and the F-22 need Superior
Control Authority and that is a function
of control surface area the larger the
elevator the larger the pitch control if
a control surface is working a double
roll where rotor and elevator action is
needed at the same time it reduces the
Control Authority so both planes also
feature large elevators offset by a
distance and angles to prevent Corner
Reflections we can see many more
trade-offs in design by comparing the
f117 and the F-35 in the quest to Phil
both stealth and fighter requirements
both the F-117 and B2 have their Engine
air intakes mounted on the upper surface
of the plane which prevents ground-based
radar from bouncing around inside the
intake and back to the receiver and
helps reduce infrared heat signatures
however for a plane expected to make
high angle of attack Maneuvers in life
and death situations this isn't a design
you would want to include while
performing a maneuver like this the air
intake will receive lower pressure air
which will lower performance right when
performance is needed most air intakes
located underneath the aircraft like the
F-16 will cause too much radar return so
twin intakes located on either side of
the fuselage are instead chosen these
air intakes have some clever aerodynamic
features too this seemingly innocuous
bump plays an important role this is
Aeronautical Engineering epitomized
every seemingly insignificant design
feature has a purpose mounting engine
intakes along the body of an aircraft
comes with some issues that pylon
mounted engines avoid as air travels
along the length of the body air begins
to form a layer of slow-moving turbulent
air called a boundary layer if this air
is allowed to enter the engine it not
only lowers performance but it can also
damage the engine as the turbine rotates
it will pass through the slow boundary
air on one side and then fast stream
free air on the other this means the
force on the turbine blade changes for
each and every rotation causing cyclical
bending a recipe for fatigue failure
planes like the F-16 feature a boundary
layer diverter that separates the inlet
from the fuselage with a small Gap but
this design increases radar
cross-section and increases drag later
variants of the F-16 tested the DSi the
divertless supersonic Inlet essentially
a large bump that creates a region of
compression that push is the boundary
layer air away from the inlet while also
scattering incoming radar and lowering
drag the test flight demonstrated that
it could meet performance requirements
ushering in its introduction to the F-35
the final product reduces waste by 30
percent and lowers production and
maintenance costs moving down the plane
we can see other hints of stealth design
long sharp edges are the enemy of
stealth sharp edges causes radar waves
to scatter in all directions radar can
even travel along the length of a
surface in the form of a traveling wave
and then scatter upon reaching the
trailing Edge the strength of that
return signal can be reduced with a few
clever techniques the strength of the
signal will depend on the length of the
edge so the first technique is to reduce
the edge length with serration you can
see this technique implemented very
clearly on the trailing edge of the B2
however it's less obvious where it's
used for the F-35 until you start
looking at all the access hatches hidden
around the aircraft every single
unavoidable surface gap on the aircraft
has a serrated edge this hatch opens to
reveal a telescoping ladder to allow
Pilots to climb in and out of the
aircraft these open to reveal the
landing gear these are the internal
weapons Bay essential for keeping the
radar reflecting missiles hidden from
View and and these smaller hatches are
flared dispenser doors
flares are effective decoys for
heat-seeking missiles but they do
nothing to prevent radar-guided missiles
in the face of radar-guided missile
proliferation and continued growing
sophistication in the technology a new
decoy system was developed this new
technology is released from this panel
when needed this access door opens and a
transmitter begins to reel out to a safe
distance behind the plane it has three
levels of countermeasures to protect the
F-35 from Attack first it actively jams
missiles while they attempt to lock onto
their targets by emitting jamming
signals which the onboard computer
computes and delivers to the emitter
through the fiber optic toe line if the
radar manages to obtain a lock it then
begins to attempt to break the lock
disrupting the tracking algorithms
guiding the missile towards its Target
finally If All Is Lost and the missile
is bearing down on the aircraft the
emitter begins to simulate the
aircraft's radar signature drawing the
missile toward it as a decoy these
serrated hatches hide critical
components of the F-35 but more can be
done to reduce Edge scattering in these
locations you may notice that the color
around these edges is different to the
rest of the plane this is because the
edges are treated with a special radar
scattering tape in the same way
traveling waves scatter when they meet
an edge discontinuity they will scatter
when traveling over a change in
conductivity the F-35 uses this to its
advantage to scatter waves over a longer
distance reducing the return signal by
spreading it out the tape has a
conductivity gradient gradually
decreasing its electrical conductivity
causing radar waves to scatter at each
interval slowly decreasing the intensity
of the surface wave before it reaches
the edge where would have released one
large return if the tape was not present
the surface of the plane itself is also
composed of a specialized radar
absorbing material in 2010 Lockheed
Martin filed this patent for a carbon
nanotube infused composite material that
can absorb radar waves from 0.1
megahertz through to 60 gigahertz this
is an incredibly wide range of
frequencies notably covering the
frequencies Russian surface-to-air
missiles like the advanced s-400 system
uses the effect traveling surface waves
have on stealth design can be seen
elsewhere
you would imagine a cylinder would be a
great way to scatter radar in all
directions lowering the strength of the
return signal but if a radar wave comes
in tangentially to a cylinder and the
wavelength is at least one tenth the
cylinder circumference the wave can
actually travel around the outside of
the cylinder and travel straight back to
the receiver this is likely why the F-35
features a sharp edge breaking up the
circular nose cone where the F-16 has a
nearly perfect circular nose cone the
F-35 features a ridge
the largest hatch on the plane is
strangely not serrated and this is for
good reason this hatch hides the
powerful lift fan within the airflow in
and out of this lift fan needs careful
consideration the left fan is
essentially a tiny helicopter capable of
generating 85 kilonewtons of vertical
thrust and in doing so creates a low
pressure Zone above the plane violently
sucking air into the aircraft at a 90
degree angle this air has to travel over
the hood to reach the inlet and thus the
hood needs to allow air to smoothly pass
over it without creating too much
turbulent flow which would lower the
performance of the lift fan this is why
the inlet door is not serrated as the
sharp edges would cause distortions in
the flow this HUD alone went through
several design iterations to optimize
the airflow flowing over it the
demonstration x35 aircraft had two doors
opening towards the side of the aircraft
but this was changed for the final
aircraft in favor of a rear-hinged door
this helps funnel air into the engine
and improves pressure recovery on short
takeoffs where the f-35b does not take
off vertically instead using the lift
fan and directional thrust of the rear
nozzle to take off on extremely short
runways the way this aircraft transforms
to perform vertical landing and short
takeoffs is astounding it's the closest
thing to a Transformer we have ever
created
when the time comes a clutch linking the
extended drive shaft of the f-35's
engine begins to transfer 29 000
horsepower to the bevel gear of the left
fan spinning the Contour rotating lift
fan blades simultaneously gears begin to
rotate in the rear exhaust nozzle the
mechanics of this nozzle are another
Wonder to behold called the three
bearing swivel nozzle it is composed of
three airtight segments cut at Angles
relative to one another we can change
the shape of the nozzle by rotating
these angled pieces separately these
three pieces rotate together to smoothly
transition thrust downwards but it's
easier to understand how it works by
seeing what happens when we rotate
segments individually
rotating the central piece can take the
nozzle from zero degrees down to 45
degrees this position is used for short
takeoffs splitting the engine's power
between thrust and lift this mode is as
impressive as the vertical takeoffs
allowing the plane to operate from
shorter amphibious assault ships like
the USS Mackin Island a ship just 258
meters long its minimum takeoff distance
decreases even further with the aid of a
ski jump a ramp that has been added to
smaller amphibious assault ships
watching the F-35 take off over such
short distances is incredible in this
clip we can see the rear nozzle quickly
adjusting its angle of thrust in sync
with the rear elevators to adjust the
pitch of the plane to ensure a safe
takeoff for a vertical Landing the final
nozzle segment can rotate to provide the
full 90 degree turn the first nozzle
segment can rotate to move the nozzle
from side to side but here it's needed
to ensure the thrust doesn't moves
sideways as the nozzle transitions as we
saw when we rotate the segments
individually they move in an arc that
would cause the F-35 to spin out of
control this mechanism also allows the
F-35 to smoothly transition from Crews
to Vertical flight and from vertical
flight to Crews when needed there are
additional control mechanisms to ensure
this precarious Balancing Act does not
go wrong bleed air from the main engine
bypass is siphoned to two roll nozzles
located on each Wing providing thrust
far away from the plane's Center of
pressure to control roll
there are also guide veins located
underneath the left fan these can adjust
the outlet area to adjust the
performance of the lift fan but can also
control the thrust of the left fan from
5 degrees forward to 42 degrees
backwards with computer assisted control
of these control mechanisms the F-35 is
remarkably stable compared to its
predecessor the av-8b Harrier allowing
the single engine of the F-35 to hover
on two columns of air to do this the
f-35s engine the f-135 developed from
the f-119 engine of the F-22 Raptor had
to be incredibly powerful the F-22
Raptor is a twin-engine fighter giving
it plenty of Excess power to pull off
incredible Maneuvers the F-35 only has
one engine and needs to squeeze out all
the power it can get to perform a
vertical Landing where the f-22's engine
can generate 156 kilonewtons of thrust
the f-35s can generate 109 one the
f-35's engine has a much larger fan and
bypass ducting giving it twice the
bypass ratio of its F-22 counterpart
providing the F-35 with a more efficient
engine for Crews but also a higher mass
flow rate for higher thrust however this
does come with some drawbacks air that
travels around the engine core
completely avoids the combustion chamber
and thus misses out on the acceleration
generated there reducing the exhaust
velocity this reduces the top speed of
the plane the max speed of the F-35 is
1.6 Mach and while it's the first plane
capable of vertical flight and
supersonic flights the F-22 can fly at
2.2 Mach the F-35 was optimized for
loiter time not speed however all that
extra waste needed for vertical takeoff
seriously hampers that ideology the
Lifan module weighs 1.2 tons waste that
does nothing in normal flight and
requires more fuel to carry and to make
matters worse that space is used for
internal fuel tanks for its variants
making the left fan as light as possible
was pertinent to making the f-35b viable
in the battlefield the fact it only
weighs 1.2 tons is astounding it
contains two counter rotating titanium
Bliss blisk meaning the blades and discs
are all one single piece instead of the
traditional alternative of creating a
disc and attaching blades through
dovetail connections this improves
efficiency and eliminates a potential
site of failure in the connection this
is an astounding feat of manufacturing
and the first stage fan takes it even
further the first stage blades are
Hollow to safe ways where the f-35b
truly comes into its own however is in
its modern Suite of sensors and
computers all feeding into this the
heads-up display incorporated into the
Pilot's helmet traditional heads-up
displays like those of the F-16 are
incorporated into a panel in the cockpit
a panel which the pilot can't see while
scanning their environment situational
awareness is everything in the heat of
combat and this helmet does everything
it can to keep the pilot informed even
giving them x-ray vision and night
vision information from a suite of
sensors around the plane feed into a
central computer where it is processed
and displayed through a projector inside
the helmet inside this transparent
faceted box underneath the aircraft is a
suite of sensors but those are not your
typical Windows these windows are made
from a notoriously expensive gemstone
Sapphire one of the few materials that
is both hard and durable but also
transparent to a broad range of
electromagnetic wavelengths from
ultraviolet to infrared however the
radar antenna hidden inside the nose of
the F-35 is the most important part of
this electronic system this is a scanned
array radar that works very differently
to traditional mechanical radar phased
array antennas have hundreds of tiny
antennas we can see metal plates set in
rows in the F-35 phase array antenna the
metal plates have slots cut into them
and each and every one of these slots is
an antenna 1600 in total this allows the
phase array antenna to steer its radar
using constructive and destructive
interference
two antenna released two radar waves at
the exact same time with their peaks and
troughs lined up it will result in
constructive interference increasing the
amplitude of the radio wave however if
the radio waves are set 180 degrees out
of phase matching the Peaks to troughs
it will result in complete destructive
interference canceling out the wave
completely this is how noise canceling
earphones work they listen to the
background noise and then release a
canceling sound wave to create silence
phased array antenna use this phenomenon
to steer the radio waves preventing the
radar from becoming a giant Beacon
leading enemies straight to it
traditional phase array antennas are
passive meaning every antenna in the
array is driven by a single transmitter
and receiver this would mean it can only
point in One Direction and if it
encountered two enemy planes flying side
by side and they split up the passive
phased array antenna would no longer be
able to track both of them
however the f-35's phase array antenna
is an active phased array meaning each
and every one of these antenna is an
individually driven transmitter and
receiver meaning the F-35 can track
multiple targets at once with zero
moving parts
the nose cones hiding these antenna need
to be transparent to radar waves and are
usually made from glass fiber Composites
as a result this transparency causes
issues for the plane's radar return
signature as an antenna like this will
reflect signals this was a much bigger
issue for mechanical radar dishes that
needed to point at the enemy to keep
track of them the face array can point
towards multiple targets while staying
in a single position and this is why it
is pointed skywards to bounce incoming
radar to space
the phased array antenna also acts as
the plane's communication antenna and
this is critical to the f-35's battle
Doctrine the F-35 excels in battle
because of its networking abilities
relaying information between its
Squadron this is a huge amount of data
to transfer between aircraft and allies
on the surface and requires a high data
transfer speed however communication
comes with one glaring problem it
announces your presence to anyone
listening it is vital that stealth
planes can communicate with each other
securely and the active phase array
antenna facilitates this the F-35 uses
the latest data link system madl
improving on the experiences learned
with the F-22 allowing the F-35 to
quickly share data securely from
Individual f-35s and ground-based
systems this information is then sorted
by the computer and presented to the
pilot in their heads-up display right in
front of their eyes giving them
unparalleled situation awareness there
is no need to communicate with their
wing mates if there is an adversary
underneath them the planes communicate
and feed that data right into the helmet
allowing the pilot to look underneath
the plane and see the location of the
adversary themselves this is the true
strength of the f-35b it is a networked
hive mind stealth fighter capable of
taking off from a ship a fraction of the
size of an aircraft carrier and
returning while hovering in the sky like
a helicopter it's one of the most
remarkable pieces of military technology
ever created
the F-35 has borrowed many lessons
learned from Planes like the F-117
Nighthawk and B2 planes that we have not
made documentaries about yet but are
friends over at mustard half their B2
documentary is 20 minutes of beautifully
crafted story filled with stylish 3D
renders if you liked this video you will
definitely love these Originals you can
get access to them by signing up with
the real engineering Link in the
description you can sign up directly to
nebula for just four dollars a month or
forty dollars a year an incredibly good
price to help us build the best
creator-owned streaming platform in the
world or you can use the Incredible cost
saving hack of signing up to the nebula
and curiosity stream bundle and get both
streaming services for just 14.79 a year
getting access to all of curiosity
stream's award-winning documentaries and
nebula's amazing and ever-growing
catalog nebula is a game-changing
platform we gathered all of our favorite
YouTube creators in one place to give us
the power of a collective funding our
best ideas for documentaries like our
Battle of Britain and Logistics of D-Day
series and real Sciences becoming Human
series we even funded Patrick Willems
feature-length film that I feature in in
a scene alongside Darren Aronofsky that
would not be possible on YouTube
we also upload early and AD free on
nebula giving you early access to Sam
from Wendover and eyes Antics on jet lag
the game along with exclusive behind the
scenes videos like The Layover after
show and our extended interview from
David curtley from helion we have many
more documentary shoots planned for the
year with fascinating companies and we
will be releasing behind the scenes
footage for them all you get all this
while helping us build a platform that
unlocks our creativity from the shackles
of an algorithm-driven platform signing
up with the link in the description is
the best way to support this channel
while getting some amazing entertainment
and education in return